decades of galactic duels daddy issues
and a four
billion dollar corporate buyout all came
to a climax in 2019 star wars the rise
of skywalker
the ninth and most likely final movie in
the skywalker saga closed out disney and
lucasfilm sequel trilogy in ways that
fans and critics alike continue to lock
lightsabers over
this being star wars we're talking about
the arguments amongst fans may well go
on forever
however petty the squabbles might get
some of the things pointed out by the
most
obsessive star wars enthusiasts really
are worth doing a double takeover
one such fan went viral on the star wars
subreddit in august 2020 for pointing
out what they deemed quote
one of if not the dumbest moments in all
of star wars
that user who goes by the name the
truest eva was referring to a pivotal
scene from none other than the rise of
skywalker
and no matter how you feel about the
movie you might just find yourself
agreeing with their point
early in the film ray finn and poe
travel to the desert planet pasana
searching for an important relic called
a sith wayfinder
while the journey proves fruitless in
that regard all hope is not lost for our
heroes stumble across a dead jedi
hunter's dagger that may lead them to
the wayfinder if they can translate the
sith inscription on it
they of course turn to c-3po fluent in
over 6 million forms of communication
for help as the droid explains however
the imperial senate restricted droids
from speaking the sith language many
years earlier
he fails to provide the translation and
it doesn't take long for the first order
to come and steal the dagger
and chewbacca after some dramatic
sequences of planet hopping antics
backup plans and a rescue mission
they managed to both retrieve the dagger
and hack the translation out of c3po's
memory banks
it all leads to the reveal that the
wayfinder they seek lies in the ruins of
the second death star
on one of endor's moons oh and they also
learned that the blade was used to kill
rey's parents
this thing's got more uses than a swiss
army knife once the team reaches the
moon where the second death star
fell ray pulls out the dagger to see if
it holds any additional clues
indeed it does wielding the dagger
before her after discovering a tape
measure-like
extension in the cross guard she aligns
its ridges with the broken form of the
second death star
which points directly to the imperial
vault where the sith wayfinder should be
the whole scene is a little too perfect
giving reddit full leeway to rip right
into it with a mix of humor and genuine
disappointment in this perceived insult
to the audience's intelligence
how would any of this actually work
aside from the dagger existing as a plot
convenience
the scenario raises a slew of questions
should the contours of the dagger lining
up with the devastated death star ruins
in a scarily accurate fashion be
explained away as the will of the force
how about the fact that rey landed the
millennium falcon not an inch away from
where she needed to be in order to
perform this incredible feat of movie
magic was it just a coincidence that she
approached the wreckage from the perfect
angle
how does that even make sense of course
this is hardly the first questionable
moment to find its way into a star wars
movie
over its 40 plus year history the saga
has had its fair share of glaring plot
holes
confusing mcguffins and weird decisions
galore
in return of the jedi luke and leia have
an emotional conversation before luke
leaves to confront darth vader and
emperor palpatine
a beautiful character-building scene
save one plot hole
aware that their siblings luke asks if
leia remembers her real mother at all
and she does recalling that she was
beautiful kind but sad
as audiences would learn more than 20
years later however
her mother padme died during childbirth
meaning neither luke nor leia would
remember her
call it hindsight bias but it stands out
when watching the film today
the plot of the force awakens meanwhile
hinges on a map detailing luke's
whereabouts that's been hidden inside
bb-8 by poe dameron who in turn received
it from the mysterious lor centeca
it's eventually revealed that this map
is just an incomplete fragment
and the rest of the information is
actually stored in r2d2 who has been
completely deactivated since his old
master disappeared
we can overlook our questions about the
unlikely journey of this map but it
still doesn't make a whole lot of sense
why r2 suddenly awakens at the end of
the movie seemingly unprompted
just in time for the big reveal as for
other weird and controversial decisions
take your pick jar jar binks his entire
existence
vader screaming no as he saves luke from
palpatine and george lucas's revised
version of return of the jedi
midichlorians determining force
abilities and so on
the list spans the galaxy but so does
our love for this wonderfully flawed
space opera
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]